okay we're now going to look at
something in physics called the
resultant force now the first thing I
want you to think of when you hear
resultant force is to think about the
overall force acting upon an object
okay so resultant force is essentially
the overall force so imagine that I've
got an object right here let's say this
is a big rock if I've got one person
pushing the rock from this way we've got
a force acting in this direction if I've
got someone else the other side pushing
the rock the other way I've also got a
force acting in the other direction now
let's say this person here is much much
stronger than this person here this
person will be applying more force so
this person let's say could be applying
four hundred Newtons
remember Newtons of the unit for force
whereas this person here is applying a
force of 200 Newtons less force so what
is the overall force going to act on
this object if we've got two different
forces acting in the opposite directions
well this object is going to move this
way because that is the forces aren't
balanced and it's going to be an overall
force of 200 Newtons how did I get that
well it's 400 Newtons this way but then
I need to subtract 200 Newtons
which was the other way so this gives us
a resultant force of 200 Newtons in that
direction notice how my resultant force
has a direction okay next up another
example now let's imagine that we've got
the same situation but this time this
time and the person in purple this
person has gone to the gym they've got a
lot stronger so this time we've got the
same situation that both pushing in the
opposite directions but this time
they're both applying a force of four
hundred Newtons
what's the resultant force well because
those forces are acting in the opposite
direction the resultant force is
actually zero because the two forces are
balanced so there's no overall resultant
force in either direction okay next
example what we have now the same
situation but now both of the characters
have decided to push the rock from the
same side so now they're both applying a
force in the same direction so what is
the resultant force going to be now
because the force is applied in the same
direction instead of taking one away
from the other we're going to add them
together because both forces are in the
same direction for this time the
resultant force is 400 plus 400 remember
Newton's which equals the resultant
force of 800 Newtons I haven't quite
finished because my resultant force aog
Newtons in that direction now one more
example I'd like to put so let's say
that I have this object here now
sometimes yet I've just got this object
here let's say these are the forces
acting upon it
we've got force of 200 Newtons in that
direction 400 Newton's in that direction
but this time we're going to think about
the forces in these two directions as
well so let's say that's 50 Newtons up
and 50 Newtons down how do we calculate
this resultant force so first of all
we're going to look at the resultant
force in this plane here so vertically
as we can see because we've got 50
Newtons in either direction
these forces are balanced so the object
will not move in either direction there
will be no resultant force in either
direction whereas because these are not
balanced here we have a greater force on
this side than this side so to find the
resultant force here we do 400 take away
200 which equals 200 Newtons
so there's going to be a force of 200
Newtons
that way in this direction so key things
to remember resultant force means
overall force if the forces are in the
opposite direction
we'll take one away from the other if
they're in the same direction we add
them together and if they are balanced
that are the same in either direction
they cancel each other out and that's it
thank you